page facebook.com slash book TV and on
behalf of the entire staff welcome it's
a pleasure to have you here and it's a
pleasure to be hosting Walter Shapiro
and hear him discuss his book hustling
Hitler the Jewish vaudevillian who
fooled the Fuhrer if you have any noise
making devices please take a moment now
to turn them off and Walter will discuss
his book for about 25 minutes and then
take as many questions as we can fit
into 20 minutes more we encourage
questions we just need to use a
microphone it's in a center right here
by the pillar both so everyone can hear
and also for our c-span audience and
after the Q&A it's a great help if you
fold up your own share and just place it
against the bookshelf
thank you and the signing line will be
right up here at this table and books
are for sale up front where you walked
in in hustling Hitler Walter Shapiro
tells the story of Freeman Bernstein
flim-flam man vaudeville manager boxing
promoter card shark writer of worthless
IOUs and ultimately the man who pulled a
con on the Nazi government which
resulted in one of his many arrests and
of course Freeman Bernstein is Walter
Shapiro's great-uncle
although Walter does not appear to have
inherited his uncle's criminal
tendencies Walter did perhaps
inheritance at a sense of hustle a
Walter Shapiro has covered every
presidential election since 1980 which
makes ten and has written for roll call
politics daily USA Today Time Newsweek
and the Washington Post among others he
has also served as Washington bureau
chief for salon as a speechwriter in the
Carter White House and as a lecturer in
political science at Yale University and
we're very pleased that he's here
tonight so please welcome Walter Shapiro
Wow
first of all I really want to thank
politics and prose which is one of the
world's great bookstores and I love
independent bookstores and I
particularly love that politics and
prose is thriving now looking around I
don't know how many of you are old
enough to remember on the old old 1950s
TV show this is your life where well
that's a little bit how I feel looking
around the room and seeing so many old
friends eh so let me start off by that
this book really starts with my father
my father what he died in 2004 was a
Connecticut city planner a mild-mannered
city planner it's a bourbon Connecticut
who went to Zoning Board hearings in the
evening I mean we're talking about a
racy upbringing I had but he my father
kept talking about his uncle his uncle
Freeman my grandmother's older brother
and he she kept saying he was really big
in vaudeville he knew people like Sophie
Tucker he married a showgirl and
ultimately he cheated Hitler on a nickel
deal now wait a second we are in a
suburban Connecticut living room this
makes no sense it was like my father
taking me aside and saying you know son
you're a direct descendant of Sitting
Bull okay my father after my father died
I didn't really think about Freeman
Bernstein until 2010 when a visiting
cousin from Paris showed up and the
visiting cousin Alan Petrovsky a second
cousin was from a branch of the family I
didn't even recognize the name we were
not a close family and he is doing
genealogical research not for him but
for his sister so there what Donna so
there we are two guys will go out of
lunch at Barney Greengrass the sturgeon
King
and we are desperately trying over
sturgeon eggs and onions which I
recommend to everyone on the Upper West
Side we are desperately desperately
trying to maintain conversation and it
is flagging because how much too fat can
you talk about family among two people
who don't care about family after about
45 minutes in where we were about to
lapse into thoughtful silences he says
to me you know the only interesting
thing I ever heard about my family was
that I had a great uncle who cheated
Hitler wait I had a great uncle who
cheated Hitler so I was told by a very
unreliable narrator my father and I took
enough college anthropology to know that
there were two tribes on two islands in
the Pacific Ocean 2,000 miles apart and
they both have religion based on the
arrival of a white ship there probably
was a white ship now we are we are about
to deal with the first lucky thing in
doing hustling Hitler and that is that
my great uncle's name was Freeman
Bernstein don't ask me where it came
from
but that had he been his brother's name
Sam Bernstein do you have any idea what
it'd be like to try to find the right
Sam Bernstein I I mean who so I went to
all right let's be honest I could brag
about my research methods but they
really started off with mr. Google I
typed the name Freeman Bernstein with
quotation marks into Google and I expect
it to only come up with a podiatrist in
Minneapolis
maybe instead the first clip that pops
up was from the Los Angeles Times of
February 20th 1937 metals broker denies
bilking Hitler and it recounts how one
Freeman Bernstein metals dealer Jewel
and Porter
and former vaudeville manager had been
arrested at midnight in the back of the
chauffeured limousine smoking his cigar
having just left Mae West's apartment
the charge that mr. Bernstein was
arrested on was cheating the Nazis on a
nickel deal for scarce Canadian nickel
it was he had been indicted in from New
York and this was a fugitive warrant in
Los Angeles and okay I'm pretty hooked
in this story at that justice point but
the moment that really hooked me was the
last paragraph of this 1937 unsigned LA
Times story mr. Bernstein asked a
visiting reporter for a cigar in in Los
Angeles County Jail when told there was
no cigar available he settled for a
cigarette and blew a perfect smoke ring
I mean we forget the Surgeon General for
a moment I mean what we're talking about
I wanted to be related to someone after
24 hours in LA lockup
could still blow a perfect smoke ring
this got me started on the quest and the
next moment came when in the New York
Public Library in the bowels of the New
York Public Library we I found a 50 page
pamphlet that why do I feel like was not
in heavy demand among the four million
cop books of the New York Public Library
it was a pamphlet by Freeman Bernstein
entitled was Hitler's nickel hijacked
and reading it I discovered that if you
believe his story somewhere on the high
seas between Canada and Germany a other
boat came up with the exact same weight
of the nickel in Canadian scrap metal
and substituted the cargo okay in the
book there was one other thing that sort
of got my attention
Freeman Bernstein a Jew born in Troy New
York in 1873 claimed that he met with
Chancellor Hitler and in Freeman's
telling hair Hitler spoke flawless
English a by Agra a biographical detail
that has been subsequently lost to
future historians I mean it's amazing
how sloppy historiography is where
particularly when you have original
sources that was enough in fact I was
going through one of the ups and downs
of journalism and my wife Meryl was with
me and I turned to her and said I know
they say in times of trouble you can
depend on your family but this is
ridiculous one tip for all apprentice
authors out there it really helps to
sell a book if you can get Adolf Hitler
and Mae West into your opening paragraph
and neither as a metaphor I spent five
years researching the life of Freeman
Bernstein a person who variety in his
1942 obituary called
a fabulous vaudeville character of
yesteryear because the nickel deal was
just the end of a long career of both
successes as a vaudeville manager and as
a silent movie producer abject failures
and rather interesting interesting
approaches to honesty in fact this it
fits it into sort of the Jewish
framework in America you've read all the
immigrant stories with your Jewish or
not first-generation immigrant grows his
way across America shows up speaking no
English but as inspired by the Statue of
Liberty work goes to work in a garment
factory works 18 hours a day goes to
shul on Saturday
only to put young David through Medical
School we've all read that periodically
we've seen the stories of the Jewish
gangsters the Bugsy Siegel's of this
world
the people for whom a submachine gun I
better not use weaponry after this week
a gun is really not a a gun is shall we
say part of their livelihood and dead
bodies sort of come with the turf but
there's a middle ground a middle ground
that no one writes about and that is
Jews who really believe that honesty is
the best policy
if you are born a wasp and if you were
if you were given membership in the
Union League club at birth for them
honesty works fine for people without
those advantages honesty works only when
it's convenient anyway that got me
started down this road and I can't tell
we tell all of Freeman Bernstein's life
but I can tell you some high points
he started off I mean he always he was
known in vaudeville for having the
loudest voice the biggest cigars the
most outlandish dreams and the biggest
reputation for not paying his bills I
mean he was but he was successful enough
variety called him the the biggest
small-time agent which meant that he
booked vaudeville acts into places like
Scranton Pennsylvania Syracuse New York
the town's not big enough for the
Orpheum circuit or the Keith albey
circuit in the East Coast and he had
relatively sometimes major figures on
the way up both George Burns in his
autobiography and uh and actually a Mae
West also claims that he helped her get
gave her her start on stage and the
point about all of this is he wasn't
a nobody but he kept his his dreams
always surpassed his income for example
for example in 1904 he had the dream
enough with the Orpheum circuit it's
time for the Bernstein circuit so he
gathered together 17 theaters in the
places like Scranton Harrisburg places
like that guaranteed them split week
entertainment two shows a week a
Bernstein production and it worked like
a charm until he had to change acts the
fact is that in vaudeville the only way
to get people coming back like the
old-time movies is there had to be
something new each Monday and the
problem was the gate receipts weren't
big enough to book a second year of good
acts so he had to book a second year of
very bad acts very talentless people and
eventually the gate receipts became such
that there was only enough money for one
train ticket out of town I'll let you
guess who got it in vaudeville he
specialized in a subsea set of
vaudeville called in those days freaks
and what freaks were they were reality
TV if you were the other woman in a
famous divorce case which ended with
your notoriety there is Freeman trying
to book you at $10,000 a week yeah one
of the people he booked regularly was
someone by the name of mayyyyyo he may
Yohe
in the 1890s was an American young
Cobley actress who hit London and took
up with the British royalty particularly
Lord hope the owner of the Hope Diamond
and mayyyyyo he actually had the Hope
Diamond for about seven years until she
ran off
with someone more attractive and
decidedly less wealthy so
down-on-her-luck
Freeman would put her on to stumble
around on stage for $1,000 a week he did
things like this but eventually
vaudeville dried up by 1914 silent
movies were really killing the good days
of vaudeville and he was broke I mean he
was really broke and he and his show I
have to mention that he and a showgirl
wife Mae Ward had declared bankruptcy
twice each and the only time he was
embarrassed by this was May wards first
bankruptcy she was a vaudeville star was
on page 1 with a picture of the New York
world three years later when she
declared bankruptcy again it was an
agate type in the New York world right
next to a failed furrier that was the
only embarrassment okay so they have to
leave town and and they just have enough
money to get to Philadelphia where
because Freeman Bernstein was one of the
most persuasive people around he gets
the local townspeople in Germantown
Pennsylvania to stake him to a silent
movie production company with his wife
as a star and his first movie which was
actually from the reviews pretty good
inspired by The Birth of a Nation it was
a reenactment of the Battle of Saratoga
called Continental girl oh you didn't
see it went Mae Ward's clambered up a
40-foot flagpole to Pacific to show the
Stars and Stripes it was just inspiring
the second film and we had a wonderful
plot may ward as this innocent girl in a
boarding school abducted by white
slavers and brought to New York
delivered debauch life only to be
rescued in the final reel by her loyal
boyfriend from the school in
Pennsylvania oh it was wonderful
except the sensors did not capture the
mood of a movie called virtue and they
focused a little too much under abort
scenes in New York in the middle and he
was banned in Philadelphia he was banned
in New York he was banned everywhere
this of course led to the business
necessity known in the annals of
American business as the insurance fire
by the 1920s he had shall we say gone a
little more rogue he and his wife who
had retired from vaudeville loved ocean
liners because Freeman was a card shark
and what he was wonderful at is fleecing
his fellow first-class passengers with
their money during the five or six days
between New York and Southampton New
York and Cherbourg and the best thing
they did was with something they called
the anniversary hustle and it worked
like this first night out in the
first-class salon they walk in arm and
arm and say tonight's our anniversary
there's free champagne for everyone we
want all of you to be our newfound
friends and celebrate with us and there
was no con I mean that the champagne was
legit it flowed it was good vintage
stuff the next afternoon normally these
wealthy people in first class wouldn't
like it when a stranger just sort of
suggests a little card game for fun but
Freeman Bernstein wasn't a stranger he
was their close friend who had been
buying them champagne the night before
invariably
by the time the boat dock Freeman made
10 times the cost of the champagne
Accords
by 1929 he was a little desperate so he
looked I don't know if you can see this
picture but he looked like a Freeman
Bernstein
however in 1929 at the Boston Garden he
organized a Irish festival under the
name of Roger or
I mean it was authentic the Blarney
Stone was authentically dug up from
behind a Massachusetts barn
the Irish Razorback pigs came from the
estate of someone named Irish I'm in New
Jersey and much more importantly the
meals were provided by Dinty Moore
actually the placemats were stolen from
Dinty Moore the Irish stew was cooked by
an off-duty policeman behind at the
Irish fair but still this was a glorious
financial success until and this is just
a shock all of you right here Oh Ryan
disappeared just before the performers
were going to be paid and this time
though he the Boston Police and the
Boston newspapers tracked him down and
they made a lot of attention to a man
they called mr. Orion Steen it's not my
joke it was the Boston Herald what Dad I
don't want to bore you with the sports
book that didn't exactly go right at the
hotel New Yorker in 1930 and the only
way to pay off the gamblers was for
Freeman to write a few I don't call them
bum checks I will call them hopeful
checks which the wish the hotel cashed I
have to say Freeman loved hotels because
they had many exits he also loved
writing checks on obscure Canadian banks
he loved them at the end of railroad
lines because he figured would take four
to six weeks for the checks to come back
marked and solvent but so but this time
after his second grand larceny
indictment it was time to relocate
leaving his wife behind Freeman
Bernstein moved to Shanghai and crowned
himself the Jade king of China it was a
very stirring investiture a little like
King Arthur in the sword in the stone
he actually traveled all over Asia to
get jewels and he developed as Mae West
actually sketches out in her
autobiography goodness had nothing to do
with it
he had a novel way of smuggling jewelry
jewels he and his wife didn't have
children but they loved animals and he
traveled with his beautiful white
Terrier and about three hours outside of
Port before facing u.s. customs the dog
was fed a mineral-rich diet and what
could be cuter than this distinguished
gentleman coming back from the Orient
accompanied by this beautiful little
ball of fluff with a slightly protruding
stomach all of this set up the Great
Khan which I will not go into too much
detail on which was he and a corrupt
metals dealer got the idea for selling
the Nazis on bogus Canadian nickel
nickel it turns out in the 1930s was
desperately needed for for military
reasons like lining the insides of guns
and armour plating in fact if you
intended to invade Poland in France you
needed nickel and Canadian nickel was
the only nickel available however the
Canadians were keenly aware of the
number of Canadian soldiers who died in
the trenches of World War one from guns
fired by Germans lined with Canadian
nickel so it was almost impossible to
export Canadian nickel so Freeman and
his partner set the word out in New York
that they had 200 tons of Canadian
nickel and if they sparked the
understandable bidding war the Germans
represented by a fellow by the name of
Otto Kafka Franz Kafka's first cousin
I am the only person who did a book on a
grifter who took out of the newer NYU
library an academic volume called
Kafka's relatives it's in the
bibliography and so the whole so all of
them working together created this
bidding war for Canadian nickel but they
kept whispering we can't label this when
we export it as Canadian nickel or the
Mounties will stop us so we'll have to
be Canadian scrap metal and whatever a
question was raised Oh we doing this way
they hide what we're doing from the
Mounties otherwise they'd find out of
course the medal had to be inspected all
that meant was a medal it's inspector
had to be bribed and Freeman this entire
deal was done with 20 pounds of nickel
not 20 tons 20 pounds that Freeman
bought a small metal shop in lower
Manhattan
this was his constant sample case it was
injected at the top of barrels in
Toronto before the when the barrels were
inspected ultimately he had the good
fortune if you're exporting something
from Halifax in March and the
temperature outside is minus 7 degrees
you can have pretty good hope that the
cargo will not be closely inspected
Freeman from his days in vaudeville knew
when to get offstage so as soon as he
was paid $150,000 about 2 million today
up front he took off for the Orient and
as when the boat landed in Hamburg and
instead of hard to get Canadian nickel
the Nazis opened up hard to get Canadian
rusted tin cans hard to get Canadian
rusted Auto bodies hard to get Canadian
discarded brake drums in fact the junk
metal dealer in Toronto pinkest Murray
called it his number 2 bundles
he was indicted through the middleman in
New York and we have left him locked up
in LA lockup where he spent two months
in jail he all of his money back he was
backed by the Hollywood Jewish community
who saw him he portrayed himself as a
martyr to the Nazis when he wasn't
claiming that the Nazis got what they
paid for and if you melt down when I
gave them there's some nickel nickel in
there somewhere
his lawyer turned out to be just on his
way up a man about town by the name of
Greg bouncer who was dating I think
dating might be the polite word the
17-year old Lana Turner but during his
despite his sleepless nights bouncer was
a very good lawyer and by rallying the
Jewish community including a major
producer by the name of Joseph Schenk
who was a co-founder of 20th Century Fox
the Governor of California quickly
figured there was more campaign
contributions to be made from keeping
Freeman's Bernstein's friends happy
rather than indict him to the New York
DA's office where there were no campaign
contributions a year later he was
indicted again arrested on a fugitive
warrant this time for those bum checks
from the hotel in New Yorker and it was
really hard to blame bum checks on the
Nazis though he tried but the governor
of California was thoughts that he
couldn't be tried for the Nazi truth
nickel he went back to New York after a
day in the tombs he announced he was
gonna help the prosecutor convict his
confederates he didn't prove to be
that's reliable a witness and after
about two and a half years of supporting
him the New York DA's office sent him
back to California I have done this as I
said with 2,500 newspaper clips and
1,500 pieces of legal documents because
the wonderful thing about being a con
man is you leave a paper
trail the only family paper I ever found
was a telegram Freeman Bernstein wrote
from Hollywood to my parents in New York
on the for their wedding in August 10th
1941 and the telegram all ten words
promises sunshine galore and then it is
signed colonel Freeman Bernstein and I
have spent a lot of time staring at that
at that telegram which I found among my
parents papers and wondering why did he
sign it colonel my father knew that he
the only time he dealt with a colonel
was when he was investigated by the War
Department for kickbacks with vaudeville
shows in encampments after the war
presumably my mother would ask my father
so who's this military hero in the
family and be set straight so I like the
picture Freeman Bernstein with a flower
in his boutonniere
charming the Western Union woman as he
sent off the telegram by signing it with
a flourish
Colonel Freeman Bernstein he died in
1942 in in December in the hotel room of
a Hollywood producer by the name of
William K Howard who was a pretty major
1930s producer what I'd like to imagine
is there Freeman when he had the fatal
heart attack was pitching William K
Howard on his life story the life story
I've told and hustling Hitler probably
he was trying to borrow five dollars
what we're out in LA a couple of years
ago I visited Freeman's grave and it is
a little Jewish cemetery now in a Latino
neighborhood outside of LA and when we
stopped to buy a little plant a little
hydrangea plant no one in the flower
shop spoke English and the cemetery had
a combination lock there was no office
on sight
so I had a call and get the combination
and I was told that his grave was row 22
Grave number 34 and I get there and I
find road 22 fine but around Grave
number 26 the grave stop and there's
just debris and I call the cemetery
office and I'm told I say I said what's
the real number there's no grave number
32 and they said it's under the leaves
so I have to remove about this much
debris leaves and old you know old
cardboard and ten years of being unkempt
and uncared for and finally I find a
foot stone not as large as this book but
as large as a paperback book and my wife
and I Merrill had a little bottle of
water in the car and with Kleenex and a
little bottle of water we tried to clean
off the foot stone and it says F
Bernstein there wasn't enough money to
give his full name and it's f Bernstein
1942 there wasn't enough money to H the
year of his birth 1873 and as I'm
standing over this neglected grave I'm
not religious it would have been I don't
it would have been hypocritical for me
to give a blessing even if I knew one so
instead I look down and I try to find
words that might bridge eternity words
that this old grifter might want to hear
and I say you are remembered thank you
[Applause]
yes oh yeah
I guess I have to pretty closely related
questions it seems like a really really
great book and a great book to make a
movie of so I'm wondering if you're
thinking along those lines and kind of
the related question is it seems like a
story that someone else might have come
across someone other than a relative or
maybe maybe another relative and so you
spent five years writing the book was
that were there points in time when you
were concerned that someone else would
get to the get to this before you did so
many questions and better than that let
me see what I can do first of all I
wasn't exactly feeling like I was in a
race with six other family members y'all
we're all Freeman Bernstein biographers
and also I didn't care about first I
just wanted to be the best no I think
there are many reasons of why Freeman
Bernstein had been forgotten for seventy
years I was not worried about the
competition
I was worried all right I'll be honest
definitely too much longer because I was
also covering politics at the same time
the publisher might get a little antsy
but I was never concerned about another
book as far as a movie and this is one
of the things I'm that yes there has a
believe it or not yet not believe it or
not yes there's been a lot of Hollywood
interest and if anyone has more interest
I can give you my details of the agents
my agent the bidding war will start soon
but seriously there has been interest
and as far as casting it I had the
perfect figure to do Freeman Bernstein
in writing the book I saw Zero Mostel in
the producers as Freeman Bernstein in a
pinch I will take Nathan Lane
in singing and I know there are five
words that could change my life George
Clooney is Freeman Bernstein am I
supposed to adjudicate questions or
planted shale so you know I'm Walters
wife but there was thank you there was
one thing that you didn't mention in
your talk and that is his relationship
with Variety magazine and his script
okay
oh thank God I have a prompter one of
the things that made the book possible
is that Syme Silverman the founding
editor of variety
fell in love with Freeman Bernstein as a
Broadway character Freeman Bernstein was
Runyon ask when Damon Runyon was a cub
reporter in Denver still learning to
drink
and as a result variety would run
Freeman Bernstein's monologues about
every three weeks for 15 or 20 years and
a typical one would start off with
Freeman Bernstein was running rubbing
lemon over last year's Panama hat ain't
it a shame he said I can't afford a new
bonnet and I have to fix up last year's
bonnet myself and we'd be off in a
rambling discussion of Freeman
Bernstein's money problems now he and
his wife even before Jiggs and mayor
Maggie of the comic strips always had
running disputes over money one night at
the top of Hammerstein's Ballroom
Freeman was the only person not wearing
a tuxedo and Syme Silverman come a
variety comes up to him and says what
you can't afford a tux Freeman he said
no I got a tux
and then he tells the story about how
Mei was after him because he knew he'd
gotten $100 fee and he was not going to
give her the money and he knew if he
ever took off his clothes she would go
through them in the middle of the night
so seemed a lot better not to wear the
tux then there was a time when he was
spied walking down Broadway in early
March in a spring ish day wearing a fur
a men's dress fur coat and a shabby coat
over it and was asked Freeman what are
you doing he said if they come home if I
leave the coat at home though they'll
attach the coat if I were it so people
can see it they'll take the coat does
the only way I can keep the coat but I
mean he loved just inventing scams I
mean beyond the hot dogs right some at
our Grant's Tomb
you know he one day he decided that he
would sell his top idea to
restauranteurs how they could get away
with small portions plates with
magnifying glasses at the bottom a
variety also charted his efforts at race
fixing which often didn't work out
exactly the way he wanted them as
variety put it his horses were over
educated as they went around the far
turn they always looked at the tote
board
but what I found and this is the most
miraculous find in writing this book and
that was in 1935 just before the nickel
scam Freeman was really down on his luck
he had no money and he had typed on the
back of borrowed stationery from Acme
liquor and wine and porters on West 57th
Street a movie treatment or his idea of
a movie treatment and involved a con man
with a heart of gold who pulls off a
race tracks staying that where his horse
comes home at 50 to one he then marries
the merry widow of a steel broker who
falls in love with him
and suddenly has more money than what he
knows what to do with he has tailors
coming in and out of his hotel suite he
also pays off every single person he
owes and this is really important
because Freeman was tremendously
generous when he had money it just
wasn't terribly often and then left with
all this money he buys the three things
that you and I would buy we had
unlimited wealth a circus a Fight Club
and the hotel in which he had been
staying in on the cuff freeman in 1935
didn't know what to do with the script
variety had maintained a vaudeville
registry service back in the days of
vaudeville that if you had a doctor skit
that ended with the doctor hitting the
patient over the head with his mallet
that was you write it down and you sent
it to variety they timestamp it put it
in a filing cabinet and if you heard
that in act five years later in Buffalo
was doing the same act you could
complain to both the variety and they
would publicize that you had registered
the script five years earlier this had
pretty much died with the Writers Guild
and the death of vaudeville and the rise
of movies but he sent it off
to variety and they're the scripts at
when variety moved their main offices
from New York to Los Angeles the file
cabinet with the registered scripts went
with it in nineteen twenty twelve as
variety was moving to smaller quarters
the Motion Picture Academy worked out
with Emerson College
that anything of historical interest
from variety we will pay for if Emerson
will catalog it and that is how
Freeman's grip blew money the name of
the horse managed to survive being Pope
Pope and miraculously appeared in 2013
and was sent to me by Emerson College
and it is the closest thing I can have
in Freeman's own voice to the wish
fulfillment of a conman who really
wanted to be a success and pay everybody
off if only he had the money anything
else I have a question I really
shouldn't because I've been going
through this process with Walter for a
long time but I think if anyone here is
a writer or if anyone here is a
researcher the most challenging thing to
me as you went through this was all of
the details and all of the research how
do you organize this and when you would
find new things was that good or were
you in despair because the material
never stopped I mean how do you write
something that's so research-intensive
well as I said this by the way is book
was only made possible by character
recognition software and the fact that
now newspapers that never had an index
are indexed that had I done this when my
father was alive of those 2,500
newspaper clips probably 400 would be
found so number one that was the great
beneficiary number two the city of New
York bless its heart throws nothing out
they're like variety and that all the
district attorney files from freeman's
nickel case had been sitting in a
warehouse in Brooklyn since 1941 when
the charges were dropped
waiting for me I also found much of the
extradition of the his 2x traditions
were well charted by the government
government of California and oh I have
my favorite my favorite find and my most
frustrating find with the State
Department Archives in 1921 Freeman
shockingly enough left a vaudeville
troupe behind in Senate Domingo
Dominican Republic and this time they
couldn't hitchhike home and the US
Consul in Santo Domingo wired the
Federal Bureau of Investigation in New
York stopped Freeman Bernstein when he
arrives on USS Eric y and then he added
these words don't believe any suave
story he may tell you he is a man who
can tell you that black is white
signed Moran of the State Department and
I really thank Moran of the State
Department but the other question is I
organized it on Evernote and the why the
State Department pulled Freeman
Bernstein's passport in 1935 I still
don't know because the State Department
stopped Freedom of Information requests
for those files because they're busy
declassifying some former Secretary of
State's top
I'm told this is the last question Oh
so how did he get people to work for him
after stranding people in Utica and Cuba
and all around the Western Hemisphere I
mean he was an unbelievably persuasive
guy
I mean it's back don't believe any suave
story he may tell you and the fact is
that he often would have people working
for him who did he had who he still owed
money from his last time around he liked
to bragged he actually got upset when
variety said he owed 150,000 he said
what are you trying to do ruin my credit
I owned 250,000 but he also was really
proud of the fact that he was the only
person who can gamble daily on the
horses for nothing in New York he was so
deep in so deep with the bookies that
they would always take him in hopes that
a long shot came galloping home and they
could see they could take his winnings
but the way he was really he had the
gift of gab I mean he was just a
wonderful charlatan a wonderful
flim-flam artist and like the best con
men he often believed his own cons he
really believed that this show it was
going to work thank you all so much
thank you to Walter Shapiro thank you
for coming if you get this remember to
fold up your chair and you can come back
up on the right-hand side and get your
book signed thanks again
perfect